all right
hello and welcome to my
presentation on artificial intelligence
or artificial stupidity
and i'll i get a little bit deeper into
into why
that is the title of the presentation is
it's not just a clickbaity title to make
you all
come and watch my talk there's actually
something something behind it and
we'll get to that um right but
uh what i'll be doing today is i'll be
telling you a couple of
stories a couple of stories about ai
about data about machine learning
and some of these stories are success
stories
some of these stories show how how
successful ai
machine learning can be nowadays
but also some of these stories are the
exact opposite they are
they are failures and especially for
those stories i would like to dig a
little bit deeper into
into these stories and figure out um why
they failed
and then talk a little bit about what we
can do
in the future to to prevent these these
failures from happening again
and when we so when i say i want to tell
you a couple of stories
um there's the uh the first thing that
comes to my mind is one of the greatest
storytellers that
we had which is douglas adams and um
i'm sure i'm sure some of you have read
this book the
ultimate hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy it has been
is relatively popular especially in the
tech community and has brought us
a couple of a couple of means
that for example 42 is the answer to the
question of life the universe and
everything
and uh that we should not panic and a
couple of other things as well and
and one of these these other things um
that i would like to point out
is it's not as popular as these two that
i just mentioned
um but it is it is a particular
interesting example especially
in this context of ai and machine
learning
and that is the babel fish so douglas
adams
um introduced this babel fish in in one
of his books
um and this bagel fish is obviously a
fictitious idea right it lives somewhere
in this douglas adams universe um
and this baby fish has a fantastic
feature it's like it's a it's a tiny a
yellow
fish and if you take this fish in
and put it in your ear
the fish then picks up on the brain
waves
of the organisms around you and whenever
some of these organisms
says something in their own language
the babel fish then absorbs that
and basically um excretes it into your
ear
in the language that you understand so
what this babyfish is practically doing
you stick it in your ear
and it translates every language in the
universe around you
into a language that you understand
now obviously um i mean douglas adams
was a very creative man
um but funny as well obviously this is a
fictitious idea
and this fish does not exist it's a
crazy idea if you will
but now let me um let me
show you something um
if i now go to go to google translate
and i'm sure i mean there are other
translate servers but
i'm sure you know this one as well as
some others
let me let me show you something hello
and here
welcome to my fortress
so i spoke in german and as you can see
on the right side
um it has perfectly translated what i
have spoken in german into english
um for you to understand i mean
admittedly i i came from this babel fish
example where you stick in your ear and
and it picks up voice and
actually speaks uh into your ear in the
language that you understand
but i think this this this translation
feature where you just speak in a
language and it is more or less real
time
translates it into a different language
it's already a feature
that that we could have not imagined
like a decade ago two decades ago
this it sounds almost like it would have
sounded as crazy as the babyfish idiot
and and
obviously you say it's not quite the
babelfish
um that douglas adams has has described
but i can show you something else
what the google is not only building
this translator this google translate
google also has these earbuds and these
earbuds
do exactly what the babel fish that's
not a fish it's not yellow
um and you still need a phone to
translate but what what these earbuds do
is
you stick them in your ear and then with
your phone
it listens to the languages to the text
to the voice being spoken around you
and thus translate it and then speak it
into your ear
just like that babyfish so this
this absolutely crazy fictitious idea
that was described by douglas adams
that um which seemed like seemed unreal
and and um almost unimaginable by
most others it's more or less reality
nowadays
and and the reason why this is reality
is because of of machine learning
that is powering power in the system and
there are multiple machine learning
models
there's a model that picks up your voice
and then translates into text there's a
model that
then does this translation there's a
model that uses the text and does text
to speech again
um and i think that is a that is a
wonderful example how
how machine learning can actually work
quite well
and can solve a um relatively big
problem that we
didn't even think of solving solving
earlier
and there are there are more examples
where where we know that
machine learning has made a tremendous
uh it hasn't has had a tremendous effect
on
on mankind like the um a couple of years
ago
um image recognition
machine learning image recognition
models started to outperform
trained doctors in identifying
cancer cells based on on visual
representation of cells like this
picture of cells
under a microscope and
machine learning models have started to
outperform
doctors by identifying these are
cancerous cells and
i think it started with breast cancer a
couple of years ago i think last
year google
released a model that outperforms
trained doctors on lung cancer
so they are and this is this is a use
case this is a
a solution that is literally life
changing
um if we if we can detect cancer cells
obviously that person
um can get help faster if um
if as with people that have not detected
it and if these machine learning models
are more accurate and better at
predicting it than doctors and that is a
clear step forward
in a good direction and it's it's a very
valuable
literally life-changing edition
but i mean i i heard the i had the title
i added artificial stupidity to the
title for a reason right because
um and i'm sure we all have encountered
some kind of
uh some kind of situation where we knew
there was some
some machine learning some technology
involved and it didn't work out
but well there were some bugs and i have
some some
relatively simple examples here on the
on the right there's a
person on twitter tweeting to indigo
which is indian airline
and he's thanking them in a in a
sarcastic tone for sending him
to kolkata and sending his baggage to
hyderabad
obviously it's sarcastic you and i pick
it up
and what i can only assume is some kind
of ai
that is answering for indigo and they
reply they are glad to hear that
so clearly they are as misunderstood at
the tone there
in the middle there's someone um
complaining to paper that they got
scammed and
again i assume there's some some ai that
is going on
and they say great we're happy that you
can see it and that is obviously
another failure um that that a person
would have not done
in this particular situation um
and um i mean these are relatively
simple examples
one of my favorite examples to show how
how ai
has failed is is this one and if you
speak mandarin you might already
be able to figure out what is going on
here for everyone else i give a little
bit of a background
so there are a few cities in china
that have introduced
video cameras on on
zebra crossings on pedestrian process
and basically there's a
there's a traffic light that helps
pedestrians hey uh i mean
if it's green you can go if it's red the
others go and you have to wait
and what these what these cameras do is
they record this this pedestrian
crossing and if it is red and someone
crosses
then obviously they're jay walking and
and then what is happening and what you
can see here is
there's a there's a big i want to say
gigantic screen
next to the crossing and um then
the the person's crossing gets like
zoomed in and is short it's like shamed
um and say hey this person just crossed
the street even though there was a
there was a red light this person just
jaywalked
but if you now look look at this photo
of that screen you can you can see
there's actually
there's actually not a peep not a person
crossing
it's a it's a bus driving which has a
green light the bus is driving
and on the bus on the side of the bus
there is a
picture of a woman printed on it
and this camera which uses image
recognition to identify that there is a
face on it
this camera has now identified the
printed face on the bus
as a person crossing the the uh
the zebra crossing obviously that is not
uh
that is not a that's not a case like
jaywalk um so
another case where uh machine learning
which is which is the part of
the image recognition has clearly failed
um and to give some context so this
woman
was not even in this city this woman was
in a different city
at that time where this got taken i
think she's the ceo of some company and
they advertised with her on the bus
but what what happened was not only did
they
display her picture on this large screen
they also sent her the notification on
her phone
because not only do they use image
recognition to identify there is a
person
they also have a database of faces
and they use face recognition to
identify
who that person is so they saw this
bus driving by i thought that is a
person figured out who that person is
and then send a message to this woman
which at that point was some differences
saying hey we just saw you jaywalking
and i think in this case it was not the
case but in other cases in other cities
um it has even gone a step further where
the fine for jaywalking
gets deducted immediately
from the person's wechat pay
account like this if you you want to
reach a paid account you need a
chinese bank account if you want to use
bank account you identify yourself
that is how that is how um the
the person is then linked to the retail
pay account and what that what they do
is they figure out as a person they
figure out who it is
they figure out the retail pay account
and then immediately within seconds
deduct the amount
that is the fee for for jaywalking
from a technical perspective this is a
this is a mind-blowing system
it's extremely interesting um what what
is possible on the technical level but
if we
if you look closer and i think this
example shows it quite well
the the implications when it fails
can be pretty bad like i mean this is a
this is a fine for jaywalking how much
can it be
um but all of this is automated all of
this relies on the correct
identification of a person and
of the correct understanding of the
situation um in that case being
a jaywalk situation or not and if we
extend that to larger crimes
or crimes with the um with the um
where the punishment is different then
there is
a lot of power in the um relies on this
this accurate identification on this on
these machine learning models to work
flawlessly without bugs and we can
already see that
that is not the case in some cases
so it's um even though it's a technical
marvel i would say on a on a different
level the question is
is the technology uh good enough to
actually be applied here
or in the bigger sense on
legal measures in general um
and i've i've said machine learning a
couple of times already i've said
ai a couple of times the all these terms
have been
have been used a lot in in the last
couple of years they are growing
continuously they've been they've been
hyped a lot by
by a lot of people um
most of the technology companies on
their website nowadays have some kind of
they're advertising that they're doing
some kind of artificial intelligence
thing to improve whatever they are doing
and i would like at least for this talk
have
a common understanding of what these
terms what these terms actually
mean or what their definition is in my
perception
and we can start with the um with the
artificial intelligence
on the right um and i i do like this
definition there are other definitions
there are other definitions of
artificial intelligence i do like this
one
um and i think is often also used
uh for all the advertisement purposes
because it is very
raw and i'll read it out quickly um
artificial intelligence is the theory
and development of computer systems able
to perform
tasks normally requiring human
intelligence
the important thing to note here is that
there is no mention of any
technical implementation there is no
mention of any
technical way how how this gets achieved
it is simply saying
something where you would usually think
a human needs to
have intelligence which is now done by a
machine
and i'll give you an example to maybe
make that point a little bit clearer if
you think about the chess program
a computer program that you can play
chess against um
typically if you play chess against a
person you would assume there's some
kind of level of intelligence
um so that checks the first box um
and then we all know chess programs
exist so then it's artificial
so it would fit this definition and now
we look at the implementation
a possible implementation for our chess
program could be relatively simple
you look at the state of the board all
the figures and all the
other positions that they're in
and then basically brute force all the
different possible moves
and then the follow-up moves and the
follow-up modes and their
their opponent's moves um in response
and if you if you just brute force all
the possible moves and the
subsequent moves at the end you you pick
a set of moves that leads to your um
to the outcome that you want which is
winning the chess match
but this brute forcing is relatively
simple right like technically it's a
i wouldn't want to write it but it's a
couple of loops it's a couple of
fl's um a couple of branches and that's
it
there's nothing like uh nothing fancy
from a software engineering perspective
so that is
and i think that is where it's often
used in advertising or often used
nowadays where artificial intelligence
does not require a certain style of
software
it is more the more the use case it
defines whether something is artificial
intelligence or not
so now when we move over to machine
learning and i think this is where it
becomes interesting
really machine learning is fundamentally
different machine learning
um does not rely on an algorithm
implemented by a software engineer
machine learning the the outcome of a
machine learning model is determined by
the data that was used to train this
machine anymore if you train the machine
learning model with different data the
outcome becomes different
technically there are some ways in it
and some things change over time
more data other changes happen um
but the general idea is that the
outcome the algorithm the way how this
machine learning model
learns to decide at the end is not
predetermined by
the software engineer writing some code
instead it is the data that defines this
and that is that is fundamentally
different than a lot of things we've
seen before
machine learning is also not new it has
just become really feasible
with more processing power that we had
in the last decade available
um and then neural networks it's a type
of machine learning a subset of it uh
modeled on on biological brains uh where
you have like neurons and they have
axions and connect to other neurons and
they're sending signals
and then there's deep learning which is
more or less only
a neural network but bigger you have
lots of different layers of these nodes
and and a lot of nodes in them basically
if you have a lot of
layers in your machine in your neural
network then it is deeper
then there's another term which is which
is data science and that is just
it can use um some of these
methodologies to then
get insights out of that so i think that
is
um that is useful to have this common
understanding for the purpose of
this talk at least and i mentioned deep
learning is just a
it's just a big neural network this is
actually a simplified view
but the um what i would want to show
here is is this one thing
that you can see that there are lots of
different nodes right in different
layers
and all of these nodes are connected
to the nodes in the other layer and this
connection is more or less
sending some kind of data um it
is not a lot of data is basically saying
yes i'm activated or
it's like some kind of number that you
want to send right
but the amount of connections that we
see here and it's like
there are so many lines already that it
becomes really difficult
to to understand what is going on here
and i'm telling you all of them are
connected but if you
if there were one connection missing you
wouldn't be able to see that immediately
right
so it's already really difficult to
understand
and see what is going on here and
the the real life deep learning new
networks
are significantly larger they can have
thousands of nodes and they can have
1500 kind of
hundreds of layers so the the amount
of connections in them are also
significantly more than shown here
and that leads to this one big
problem that machine learning
has and there are multiple big problems
i'll be talking about two today
this is the first one which is that this
this behavior is
is basically a black ops as a as a human
as a software engineer
as an as an ml engineer
it is really difficult if not impossible
to comprehend
why this particular machine learning
model
makes decisions in a certain way why the
output is a certain output
on something because it's just this it's
so complex
it becomes impossible to see and that is
that is where
um a lot of the problems that i that i
mentioned um
come from like you you can't really
understand what's going on you just
hope that it works and you have this
black box behavior where you just put in
data and hope the outcome
is correct but that is only one
of the issues with
the widespread deployment of ai and
machine learning models
i'll be talking about the other thing
now and i'll give you i'll give you an
example
of this this application that in
2011 the city of boston had a problem
and that problem was
potholes they had a lot of potholes all
across the city
on their streets and they wanted to to
fix that problem
it was 2011. they did what everyone did
when they had a problem they wrote an
app
and this app is called street bump um
worked in a pretty smart way i have to
admit that
this this app uh worked in the way that
when you
installed it on your phone and when you
were driving
across when you were going on a trip and
you were driving across the city
um you would open the app put the phone
on your passenger seat
and then drive around and whenever you
would encounter a pothole
you would there would be a bum and
the phone and and then the app would
realize okay there was a bum
um due to the accelerometer so the
notice okay there was some kind of
disturbance
um and it would then take the gps
coordinates
and send those cbs code audience to the
server and say hey this is where i
encountered a bum
um you might want to check if there's a
pothole and when there is a portal you
might want to fix it
i think it's a pretty smart idea and so
they started this
they um released the app and after some
time they realized
when looking at the map of boston they
realized most of the potholes were
in the high cost of living areas
and when you think about it that's odd
right why would
why would only in high cost of living
areas be potholes like
why only where the rich people live why
not in
in the rest of this and the problem here
was
that it was it was 2011.
not everyone had had a smartphone not
everyone had a smartphone where you
could install an app
that was relatively new actually only
the people
who had enough money would afford that
would happen in a smartphone and only
these people and these people would most
likely live in in these high costs of
living areas as well
so um you were basically i mean nowadays
everyone
every five-year-old kid is watching tick
tock videos
but 2011 was a different time so what
what
happened here was um that the data was
skewed like the data only represented a
subset
of the population of boston and it was
only the
high income subset and that's why the
data only showed
potholes in the icos of living areas
and i i must admit the way they fix this
is equally smart what they did
is they then installed this app on on
phones and gave it to public buses
public buses and garbage trucks and
basically
uh vehicles that were driving around the
whole
uh the whole city uh street grid and
therefore they create
like a actual coverage of the host the
important thing to note here the
important thing to learn from this
particular example is however that there
was no
machine learning involved there was no
blackwatch behavior that went wrong
it was solely the data that did not
represent
the actual situation the data was good
and that's why that's why this initially
failed
so that is the that is the second issue
that that i see with the
um with the wi-fi deployment of machine
learning nowadays
it is that the data is biased has a
social bias
and that is difficult to see in the
beginning and then
if you use that you will run into
resources as well
and i'll i can show you another demo you
remember
[Music]
you remember this and you might even
remember
the example that i wrote which was
was coupled
a couple of years ago that got popular
um
if i type here as a nurse and
she is a doctor and we all know that
there
is no reason why
um it needs to be he or she right we
know
every gender can be an earth and we know
every gender can be a doctor
now if we translate this from english
into a language
um that has gender neutral pronouns
like malay turkish is another one
then we lose this information this
gender information
like this basically says that some
person is a doctor and
this person says it's a nurse but it
doesn't say it's a he or she
right so now if we take this sentence
these two sentences and translate them
back into english and
and keep in mind i wrote he is a nurse
and she is a doctor we translate that
back
all of a sudden the re-translation reads
she is a nurse
and he is the doctor
now the reason for that is even though
i've called out google translate
previously because it's
working well right um and i've explained
how there's
a lot of machine learning involved the
reason for this particular issue
is that uh basically how these machine
learning models
these these texts these translation
models workers
they read a lot of text there's a
machine learning model and you feed in a
lot of text
books in one language and in the other
and over time the machine learning model
the translation model
learns out of this this particular part
in that language
translate to this particular part in
that other language
so you train it with a lot of this data
and obviously that text that all these
texts were used to train um uh i mean
they
are they are old texts they are i mean
there are texts that
existed and a lot of these texts are
historical in the way that
um they're not the latest um
and historically speaking
for whatever reason there are i mean
because
for societal reasons um being a nurse
was often associated with the theme
and the doctor was often associated with
the mail and that is how
how this machine learning model has now
learned to translate
this sentence even though there was no
gender information
in the original melee sentence the
translated version
includes agenda and that gender is based
on the historical
data that was used to train this model
there was a couple of years ago
that became popular the first time uh
with the turkish language which also
also does not have does not include
gender specific pronouns and what google
then
did is they they created this double um
this double translation where they say
hey look um
we don't know what gender it is it can
be she or it can be
the truth is that that this um for
turkish that had worked because it got
popular and then they fixed it for
turkish for other languages
it has not yet been implemented and i
also think that this
is an additional extra effort that you
um
that you would need to do on a case by
case basis which is not the ideal way if
you
widespread uh if you consider the
widespread deployment of machine
learning models
um there's another example where
data where clich clearly shows that data
being used to train a machine learning
model can be can be pretty bad
if you don't remember tay i'll give you
quickly uh a
reminder of of what this was hey was
this this chat
bought in the way nowadays you should
call it what um
this this twitter bot uh i think it
worked in other platforms as well
developed by microsoft and the idea was
hey now this um
this uh this board now
knows how to speak but it doesn't know
what to talk about like it doesn't have
context
um and basically the idea was uh
it got released to
um to twitter and the
uh the twitter world was then supposed
to feed it with text and like
train it um by talking to it and now if
you think about how
people have conversations on the
internet maybe especially on twitter
i actually i i think they are even worse
um
but if you look at people communicate
over the internet and you take that
as a baseline um how you want to change
someone just to have a conversation
maybe in retrospect it's not such a good
idea and looking
what happened it clearly was not a good
idea within 24 hours a day got shut down
and the the reason was people figured
out hey
i can just say whatever i want to say
and it will pick it up and then
learn that behavior and there are a
couple of people
clearly um abused that and
and the thought trait to become a racist
um anti-feminist uh
basically um the worst uh person that
you can be
is is what the this tables tend to be
within 24 hours it got shut down
my favorite is that at some point
someone just said hey you're a stupid
machine
and pace response is hey that is correct
um
and the reason is because i learned from
you and if you if you tell me dumb stuff
i'll repeat the dance
and there's um now you might say uh
okay that is a it's a good example of
how we can see that that the data
that we use to train models has a large
impact on how that model
behaves but it's only a twitter
bot um
it's not gonna it's not gonna change
people's life
it's not gonna impact a lot of a lot of
people's lives
where um i'll give you in the next
example which is a
the compass system the correctional
effect management
profiling for alternative sanctions
system which is used which is still used
in the us
which is a system um that if you commit
a crime
in the u.s then you are filling out some
kind of
form i think it's like 213 questions
some kind of questionnaire that you fill
out
and then this data gets fed into a into
this
into this compass system and then the
compass system analyzes it and
and makes a prediction whether you will
be
uh whether you will reoffend or not
so it's basically saying hey look i have
this data and now um
this person committed a crime and i make
a prediction whether that person will
commit a crime
again like possibly that that person has
to go to jail
and afterwards um i'll
i predict this person will commit a
crime again or not
and there was a couple of years ago
pro publica analyzed how this
system actually made these decisions and
what the outcome of this was
and the you can see the the result here
they looked at they looked at the
skin color the
ethical background ethical background of
people and look at how
how this system decided whether they
would be used
and they are to see on the table
there are basically two ways how how you
can be wrong how the system can be wrong
one is
you expect the person to reoffend but
the person does not
or you expect the person to not reoffend
but then the person
um when that go actually does does
reoffend
and you can see here that the um
that the people who were like 23 of the
white people
were labeled um a higher risk but then
didn't
get them so it's a false outcome
for 23 of the white people where they
were highest
but the same the same mistake for
african americans
was almost 45 so there's no
there's no difference like it's it's the
same questionnaire um
the the questionnaire doesn't even ask
about race it doesn't ask about skincare
um yet this system um has been
has been uh decided to uh
for 45 of the afghan members related
them a higher risk
than they actually and on the opposite
are labeling
someone a low risk um and then they do
re-offend
um was 47 more than 47 for the white
people who
were under labelled if you will
um and only 28 percent for
african-americans
so there's a clear racial bias in this
system and that system is still being
used today and this system is used to
to determine bail and sometimes even to
determine
um like prison sentences like the judge
looks at this data and then makes
makes a decision now here maybe we want
to extend the prison sentence because
the
assumption is that that person will
reoffend
and and that is um this
system has a lot of impact on people's
life and we can clearly see a racial
bias
and the reason for that again is i'm
very likely the data that was used to
train
this system um that then
um has has this uh this very racial
bias there's uh there's one more example
that i would like to talk about
uh autonomous driving vehicles it's uh i
mean there's
it not everyone is in agreement when
they will take over but they will
probably take over our seats in the next
couple of decades
largely speaking and how these work is
um a lot of them have lots of sensors
but a lot of these sensors are cameras
that film
the environment around the car and some
systems even only rely on cameras
and what they do is there's some image
recognition that basically looks around
and if they
uh if they see a stop sign then they
identify a stop sign
and the car knows okay i have to stop
here if there's a red light that stops
you know that i can go
and so on identifying other cars and
also pedestrians because
clearly one of the one of the issues
with autonomous driving cars is
if a pedestrian is crossing the street
you have to brake
i mean you have to create the least
amount of damage that you could do
and now often this image recognition
system again is trade
is a machine learning model that is
trained with data to identify these
pedestrians
and there was a study that found out
that if you are
a dark-skinned pedestrian you are less
likely to be identified
by this autonomous driving car as the
pedestrian and therefore
the car is less likely to stop
um and therefore or like circumvent or
drive around
and that is um if you think about the
amount of cars that we have on the roads
nowadays
on a global scale billions of cars um
or a billion cars if all of these become
autonomous
and if all of these are suffering from
from this
issue from this racial bias again then
there will be
there will be people who will die and
unproportionally dark-skinned people
will be affected by this
so this this algorithmic bias this this
social bias that came in probably again
through the
data that was used to train this model
because
it was probably a lot of data with the
non-dark-skinned people lots of white
people probably
um and this data and
that training that was used to then um
set up this this machine learning model
will be responsible
for uh all this um not evenly
distributed amount of deaths
and that is i think that is um something
that
where we definitely need to be aware of
that there is a big issue
that needs to be fixed before we deploy
this
on a larger scale
and in in summary i remember this when i
was a kid and i wanted something
and all my friends were doing it and my
mother
um i asked my mother hey can i do it and
she sent me no
and i said all my friends are doing it
it doesn't matter if your friends are
doing it or not you're not doing it
that is not how machine learning works
machine learning works exactly in that
way if all my friends are doing it
i'm also doing it if my in my
friend's jump of a bridge i would also
so that is
that is how the machine animals
use that data and ah
now you look at me and say i go you're
um you've been telling us there's
machine learning everywhere there's ai
everywhere
um and it is it has
it fails a lot and it has horrible uh
implications
the world is on fire is there anything
we can do about it
and the good thing is yes we can
there are in the machine learning
engineering
[Music]
domain or in the in the industry there
is a movement nowadays
that we want first class
that we want explainability
interpretability
as a selection criteria for models like
if you have a model
you need to understand why it works in a
certain way you need to understand why
this input data results in that output
data um
so basically we try to address the first
issue that i that i talked about where
it's a black box and we don't know
what's going on
we try to figure that out we try to
take extreme ability um into
consideration when we choose the model
and make the important point that we
need to have this explainability
and uh i i mentioned
a lot of the things a lot of the
examples relied on image recognition
which is
a very powerful use case for particular
deep learning nowadays convolutional
networks
there's a there's a um there's a
methodology where you can get
um more fine grade fine
detailed um information about what is
going on in that one
you can see here on the bottom how this
image recognition model works this new
network
basically each layer identifies a little
bit more information like the first
layer is just like
uh just pixels and the second layer is
identified
are able to identify edges and then you
get a combination of edges and then you
identify the facial features and at the
end
you'll be able to identify what the
uh
one example there are there are other
examples that help us um
remove this black box behavior of of uh
machine learning and and what we in
summary what we would want to do is we
want to
get away from the standard machine
learning model where we just have data
thrown in the model
and then that's how we predict things
and there will be the error
and we want to move into a situation
where we
have data and we throw it into a model
we look
into the model see how it behaves we
want it
to be interpretable we want to
understand
just things that it does and then add
human inspection
and um and uh retrain it and figure out
okay look
we missed out this particular set of
data that's why it's
it's making the wrong decisions that's
why it's making the wrong prediction
let's try it again with some other data
and basically come to a point where we
have human experience
as part of the machine learning model
training process and there's
another technology which is called lime
that i really like that helps a lot
by doing that and it's the saline stands
for local interpretable model agnostic
explanations
what that means is you can
find out it's not it doesn't matter what
type of machine anymore you have
and you can find out for your model
[Music]
and get explanations why it works in a
certain way
i'll give you give you a short example
how that works
so what happened here is there's this
picture on the on the left with
this picture of a tree frog and it gets
identified as a three-fold
0.54 uh
accuracy and what lyme does
is it basically looks at the data and
looks at the prediction
that gets out of this machine learning
model and then
does the same thing but it removes data
points
from the input so as you can see here in
the middle
um lots of the information is grayed out
so what the what line does is it it
throws away
all of that that is grayed out takes the
same takes that picture then
and um lets the machine learning model
predict again hey what do you think it
is now
and if it is the same prediction then
you know all the data that you had
thrown out
was irrelevant if it is a very different
prediction then you know the data you
have thrown out was very important to
identify it
um as a in this case as a tree flow and
you can see there's um
and the top one in the middle is um look
you can see that the important is that
the the eye
and the frogmouth has kept that even the
prediction gets a little bit higher
because the
bigger part of the image is representing
the street shot now from the perspective
of the machine learning model
and if you look in the middle um it
looks like
the data that is left in the middle is
of no indication that it is a tree fork
um and then you see on the bottom um
there were some some things got removed
and still you're identifying as a few
droppings
overlay then we've taken it now you can
figure out and that is what you see on
the bottom right
you can figure out which part of the
input data was relevant
for that prediction that it did and
that's why you can get an explanation of
why your your model
worked in a way and you can do that if
you have structured data if you have
tables
um you can throw away columns so you can
throw away like view this
there are other things that you can um
it's not just
a picture uh it is um model agnostic and
it doesn't matter
um what kind of data you have you can
just throw out some data and then see
um how it behaves with that data thrown
out
another thing that you can do is have
more diverse teams i mean that is a it's
a
common thing in the tech industry that
we are not diverse
other industries are also not diverse
but i'll
i'll remind you of the example with the
autonomous driving car
i would have i would argue that if there
would have been a diverse team
there would have been more people
thinking about the diversity of the
training data that was used
to train um the autonomous driving car
system to identify pedestrians
and if you have a diverse team you are
way more aware of differences that there
are in the real world
and if you are aware of that you think
about it more and you can
you can add that to the system that
you're building
um there's a uh another thing that i
that i really like and that is the data
ethics canvas
which gets um distributed and released
by the open data data institute
it's basically a guideline of questions
when you're working on a
data centric or a data intensive project
there are
certain questions that it helps you that
you need to ask yourself
um before starting um that you want to
that want to ask yourself to figure out
whether you're doing the right thing or
not it's like
who this data gets shared with or what
are the limitations
of these data sources um and i think
that is
that's a very helpful guideline if
you're starting this
sometimes throwing out data is helpful
it doesn't always fix your problems but
if you um
if you have a problem where if you if
you try to
work on a solution that in no way
relies on on skin color
or on one ethical background
why would you then use that data in in
your data set to train a model i mean
there's
um it's it's easy to put that here on a
slide
the the truth is that they are often
quasi identifiers
um where even though you don't
you don't have like a like a name or
like something that identifies a person
directly for example
um if you would have a data set that
does not have my name
but it has my gps coordinates and it
knows exactly
that i always go from from this
apartment building to that office
building
um then i mean now guys i don't because
i'm working from home
but um if you have that information you
could you could figure out
that this data is about me even though
none of that none of the data points
actually realized me so there's
there's a quasi identifiers but they are
in general um if you don't need the data
maybe don't throw it into a system
and try and train the system with it um
there's google facets which is a tool
that lets you explore your data set
it's relatively easy to use
just throw in your data set and then you
can play around and they have really
nice visualizations
and within within a couple of clicks you
can see
if there are some some like if you have
a
data i bought people you can easily see
ah look
um only twenty percent of my of my data
set is actually female so
clearly um i have under-represented
uh that that gender category or you can
look at eight or you can look at
all the other um categories uh all the
other data points that you have and you
can identify
whether they are um certain categories
underrepresented or over-represented
and that helps a lot to understand the
data set that
nasa's what if tool which also works
quite well with the
previous two that i mentioned google
passes and it lets you identify
um how machine learning models
work and gets you a little bit more
insights on on why decisions were made
in the way that they were made by that
that being said i hope i could give you
some idea of of the problems that we are
facing nowadays with the
um especially growing deployment of
machine learning
models and that social buyers
in data in historical data social bias
in general and data is
is a big issue and that machine learning
just picks it up
and replace that to us and if we mess up
the data
model is also messed up as well as the
fact that
machine learning models are just way too
complex
and that in order to have a correct
machine learning model and that means
that we remove these
biases but not only because we don't
want to be racist because it also
increases the quality of that model
right it could be more accurate
so and in order to do that we need to um
achieve
a model we need to have a model that we
actually are able to understand
um and and interrupted and know why
things happen
in a way that being said um
thanks very much for your attention i'm
happy for for all the questions
if there are any if you want to hello
yeah hi hey going great presentation
um i was just kind of wondering like how
worried you are about
um kind of glitches in these kind of
machine learning models being used by
you know tyrannical or perhaps in
different justice governments
and kind of organizations like how kind
of what point would you be comfortable
um with like extended i guess machine
learning use in society um for example
like you know like getting getting fined
uh by like a camera for jaywalking is
probably a bit harsh
i don't know i don't know let it freak a
lot of people out so i'm just kind of
like wondering like where do you stand
with like the the whole
i suppose like how how worried are you
about its use
i suppose misuse more and kind of what
other parameters do you think are
you would be comfortable with um in this
area with it's like you see in society
oh that's a that's a great question um
i think it depends i um
i mean it's it's um so none of like even
though i
i presented a couple of ways how we can
get better
obviously you wouldn't read perfect um
what what even is perfect right
um i think the more or less
and that is a very broad statement here
um
you would want to be better than humans
in that situation um and for example
um it's really difficult to measure
right um
i i would argue that you probably
want to have some kind of human
interaction like give you an example
where
um the like the the
the cancer identification um
i even though i know that it has
outperformed
uh doctors i would not want to have
cancer treatment just because the
machine learning model says i still want
the doctor
to look at it again and then see ah yeah
maybe there is something
let's look into that deeper and then um
identify further and see
what's going on the i
can imagine that at some point
um potentially far in the future
that we reach a point where um
we we have as a society
unders the
feeling that the machine learning model
is safe and i guess over a couple of
decades or maybe hundreds of years that
it might come to a point where we come
to that i don't know
um i don't know where the exact where my
threshold is um
clearly the there are a lot of factors
like the um
i mean the impact is a factor um there's
there's some kind of risk if it's high
impact
um like can it kill people obviously um
i would be way more cautious than
than other things that are that have a
less
yeah less impactful so i think there's
it depends a lot on on a case-by-case
basis
for now i think most of the of the high
impact should definitely have a human
intervention like i wouldn't
um i am not convinced that
finding people is is yet
based on walking is on the level where
we can confidently say that it's
mostly accurate i i do i do think that
a lot of the humans are not perfect
either like they are
like highly imperfect i would argue and
there are a lot of
situations where we can probably now use
it
to like um extend our capabilities
um but i think the real power is in fact
in
what we're looking at decades
potentially more than decades um
to a point where we potentially can
reach an amount of accuracy where we can
replace humans on it
but i i think that is that is pretty far
away i don't know where my exact
threshold is for any particular
case
thanks
any more questions i look at the chat
people remember today i hope people
learn from play also
um i'm also in the in the slack channel
so
um just uh you can leave me there
or if you want to reach out i sometimes
post medium
things um and i rarely
on twitter but if i do you can follow me
there
i can just google my name it's actually
not common
so if you google ico clusterman you'll
find me so that's good i guess
if there are no other questions thank
you very much uh for your attention
i hope it was interesting maybe somewhat
educational thanks a lot
you